طيب مشاهدينا انا وعادل اختلفنا الاسبوع
الماضي على موضوع الانجاب بعد سن الستين
انا كنت بقول هو غير يعني بالنسبه الي
برايي انه غير منطقي وعادل شايف انه عادي
جدا طبيعي طيب
اللي اعلن وهو بعمر 84 عام بانه يتوقع
مولود جديد من صديقته تصدر اسم الفنان
العالمي وعناوين منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
خلال الاسبوع الماضي ولكن بسبب اخر متعلق
بنفس الموضوع طبعا بعد ما تم الكشف عن حمل
صديقته نور الفلاح وانتظاره لمولود الرابع
منها وانت اللي راح تقولنا ليش التفاصيل
الجديده وفق التقارير صدم على الباتشينو
من خبر الحمل لاعتقاد بانه لن يتمكن من
الانجاب مره اخرى عمره 84 بسبب مشاكل صحيه
تمنعه وهي عائق لذلك وبالفعل قرر الفنان
العالمي اجراء فحص الحمض النووي والزم
صديقته كذلك بالخ ضوع للاختبار لكن
الاختبار اظهر ان الباتشينو هو والد الطفل
المنتظر فعلا من صديقته والتي تصغر بثلاثه
وخمسين عاما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات